m ce pas ta pauvre qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire sur cette audition qui
vient de se terminer suspendu pour le
moment oui effectivement donc monsieur
d'aval comme vous avez pu constater les
traditionnels s'est longuement ce matin
sans surprise puisque finalement j'ai
l'impression que toute la presse a été
informé de certains éléments dans ce
dossier il a été interrogé sur des
éléments concrets qu'on a pu lire
notamment dans la presse écrite par
rapport à ce véhicule
deux fonctions qui auraient circulé l'un
dans la nuit également par rapport à ses
empreintes qui ont été faites au niveau
des pneumatiques et puis finalement ce
drap également qui a été retrouvé sur le
corps d'alexia a répondu par rapport à
ces éléments
en tout état de cause je peux vous dire
qu'il maintient sa position savoir qui
nie toute implication dans le décès de
son épouse que les choses qui vont
s'ensuivre dans son cas c'est
malheureusement simple risque d'avoir
une présentation devant le juge
d'instruction avec un défèrement puis la
racj et finalement monsieur navale sera
mis en examen dans ce dossier
captivé répondu sur le drap côté ont
potentiellement accablant il a répondu
exactement
alors je peux pas finalement vous
exposer clairement la réponse de
monsieur d'aval il a été mis en tout cas
face à certains et certaines
constatations matérielles qui ont été
faites
gérez pas au delà au niveau des
explications qui ont été fournies par
monsieur laval ou connaissez les raisons
pour lesquelles vous expliquerez pas sur
ces points en tout état de cause les
deux enquêteurs ont pris le soin
vraiment de reprendre tout ou tous les
éléments et vous vous attendez à une
mise en examen de votre cliente avait
une gare à ces éléments qui sont on peut
lire un objectif oui